why do we put candles on birthday cake
hi there i'm arya and i love birthdays
hi i'm ray and i love to bake cakes
and today we're going to talk about the
history of birthday cake
happy birthday ray this is weird arya
cause it's not your birthday yes or
because on a base level it's a little
odd that to celebrate you emerging from
your mother's womb you expect a
beautifully decorated pastry to be set
on fire because it's not my birthday
great question ray how did birthday
cakes become the tradition that they are
today i have a story for you you knew it
wasn't my birthday apart from democracy
and a whole bunch of philosophers we can
also thank the ancient greeks for the
first burning cakes greeks would make
round cheesecakes as offerings to the
goddess of the moon artemis they then
put candles on the cake both because
they thought fire could send good
intentions to the gods and so the cakes
would glow like the moon that's such a
nice thought it's nice seems a lot like
a lot of work you know some religions
they just light a candle on fire and
they'll be like cool we're done i feel
like it's a lot of effort to get a
prayer out honestly a little bit
and while that is believed to be the
birth of the flaming cake it wasn't to
celebrate anyone's birthday one reason
was because well no one knew when anyone
was born the practice of recording
birthdays wouldn't become popular until
the christian church began doing so in
the medieval period the tradition of
throwing birthday parties for children
may date back to germany in the 1400s
they were called kinderfest or literally
children party germans believed children
were particularly susceptible to evil
spirits on their birthdays and that
candles on the cake would transport
their wishes to god families and friends
kept the candles lit all day keeping
watch until after the evening meal when
the cake would be served imagine being
like just a horrible older sibling and
you're just like i want my younger
sibling to just have a bad birthday i'm
gonna make sure that their birthday
candle is gonna be off
man
that's sadistic foreshadowing the amount
of attention birthdays demand today in
1746 german count ludwig von zinzendorf
celebrated his birthday with a giant
cake on a table in the shape of an l for
ludwig the cake had holes bored into it
according to the person's age and to
place the candles into oh and he also
had his name spelled out in two foot
tall golden letters how basic i feel
like your
measurements are a little off yeah i
i wouldn't say this is to scale but i
think if you just if you squint a little
bit
it can look pretty big squint use your
imagination if i look at through my if i
look at it through my fingers like it
looks pretty big to me this tradition
made its way to america when large
numbers of germans emigrated to
pennsylvania during the colonial period
american women became more prolific
bakers than their european counterparts
due to the relative absence of bakeries
and abundance of oven fuel aka trees the
cakes they were making however were
still pretty lame by today's standards
fruit cakes and yeasty rich cakes gross
what we think of cake couldn't emerge
until british chemist alfred bird
combined sodium bicarbonate and cream of
tartar
baking powder well an early version
anyway
finally cakes could rise without yeast
and achieve a level of light fluffiness
that had previously been extremely
difficult and time consuming no this is
definitely something
closer to what i would bake currently
it's lighter and it's less of a
red
less hockey puck like
[Music]
yeah pretty different not long after
more festive decorations and frostings
became popular back then cookbooks
included recipes for colored frostings
made from parsley and beets yum we
should try i might try it though let's
just try it
that's actually really good
wow it is not mad at that that that
tastes like good so who knows maybe the
parsley maybe there's something good
yeah
it's a oh that's a big it's a chunky
looking green
i don't know how i'm gonna feel no
wow no that really tastes like parsley
yeah the texture of the parsley you can
feel whoa cool
it's like a wheatgrass shot put into
frosting that that's messed up that's
messed up
that one we could burn
light fluffy cakes with candles and
colored frosting were given out on
birthdays sounds like the birthday cake
we all know and love right not quite yet
while it was popular to have writing on
cakes in the late 1800s they would say
things like the person's name along with
many happy returns of the day catchy so
lots of red on a cake yeah too much
effort for me so they didn't write happy
birthday no no not happy birthday you
see happy birthday didn't appear on
cakes until after 1910 with the
popularization of the song happy
birthday to you so we've only been
saying happy birthday for about a
hundred years right now it's crazy isn't
it before then you just go around and be
happy returns to you on the day
birthdays seemed like a lot more effort
back in the day a lot more effort there
were gods involved there was praying
there were giant elves
just too much effort pre-made cake mixes
were available starting around 1930 but
wouldn't become more popular until after
world war ii in the late 1930s was also
when carvel invented the ice cream cake
the gates of cake innovation were not
just open but shattered i love a good
ice cream cake i'd never make one but i
love eating a good ice cream cake why
would you pick an ice cream cake it's
too much work man
what's your favorite flavor of ice cream
mint
or cookies and cream two of my least
favorite flavors that's why we can never
be together today birthday cakes are
more elaborate than ever none more so
than a 2015 six foot long 1 000 pound
behemoth purchased by an unnamed buyer
for his daughter's birthday the cake
featured over 4 000 diamonds final price
75 million dollars it's 2015 and a guy
decides to buy a birthday cake and wants
to remain anonymous
you know that that's going to end up on
instagram somewhere the cake probably
had its own hashtag what would the
hashtag be 75 million cake cake hashtag
diamonds on my cake i like that let's
create this that's awesome man
so where does that leave us today funny
you should ask
because i kind of see them looking like
this when i think of birthday cake i
think of sprinkles bright colors and
things that just make you want to
celebrate it is a modern rainbow drip
birthday cake this is actually a giant
cake pop made to look like an ice cream
cone that is incredible right that is
incredible this is not made from parsley
right that is not made from parsley
but
modern cake for those of us who can only
dream of the ultimate birthday cake
multiple television and internet
programs showcase fancy sculptural and
complex birthday cakes as long as people
keep having birthdays the birthday cake
will continue to adapt and evolve oh
wait wait
in a study actually published in 2017
scientists found that blowing out
birthday candles can increase the
chances of bacteria being found in icing
by about 1 400
so what do we do now
not my problem happy birthday
still not my birthday it's your birthday
happy birthday
lots of happiness good luck too
congratulations on your birthday many
happy returns to you